declared by the government as a result
of covert 19 pandemic in accordance with
house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12 pursuant to executive order
2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a work session on bills
and an update on revenues please note
there is no physical location for
members of the public to observe and
listen contemporariously to this meeting
however in accordance with emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporariously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaries
listen and if necessary participate in
this meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar
and through the electronic calendar and
the dental court website
the notice of this meeting complies with
the health schools rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call 271
3600 or email hcs like dot state dot nh
dot us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
on the meeting assisting us
christopher shea and brad greenland
hopefully please note that all votes
that are taken during this meeting
should be done
by roll call vote let's start the
meeting by taking a roll call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you
during the during this meeting which is
required under the right to know law
representative bernstein could you take
the role
thank you mr chair and good morning to
you good morning everyone
it's march 23rd 2021
9 03 a.m we'll begin roll call with
representative abrami
yeah here my home and stratum alone
representative griffin
erin hudson uh my wife is in the house
someplace
representative ober erin hudson with the
six cats
good morning representative doucet good
morning
my home office in salem alone
your clerk is alan burstein i'm at my
home office in nottingham new hampshire
representative elliott i'm here in salem
and my wife is in the living room
representative jeanine good morning i'm
in my home office in salem
and uh my wife is somewhere in the house
good morning
representative nunes good morning i am
home alone in pelham
representative baxter
representative spillsbury good morning
home alone in charlestown
representative tudor morning
northwood uh wife is in the house good
morning representative almighty
boom in lebanon alone representative
ames
here i'm home i'm in my home office
alone in geoffrey
good morning representative southworth
here
in dover alone representative malloy
here at home in greenland uh alone
representative thomas schamberg thank
you representative burst gene
i'm in wilmot in my office alone good
morning representative tucker
representative gomarlo i'm here in
swansea alone
representative laughman
representative amanda gorg it's nice to
have you back
oh thank you uh good morning i am here
alone
representative mary hacken phillips
morning i come to you from my office
alone in concord new hampshire
representative james murphy good morning
i am alone in my home office in hanover
our esteemed chairman representative
norman major
good morning i'm in my office at home
and my wife is in the house
mr chair currently there are 20 members
present four members are not present
thank you representative bernstein
all right this morning like to do two
things
go over the bills that are in our
possession that we haven't acted on
we have six house bills
and five uh five senate bills
and we'll go through all those and the
idea is today
is to find out do we need more
information
and uh or are they set to be exact
we will exec i hope all of them tomorrow
but we're not exact today and then
after that i'll give you an update
on the meetings
with pat and i and the leadership of the
finance committee
and the status of our revenues within
the finance committee i sent you an
email this morning
with the amendment to house bill 1
which has our updated revenues in it
also i sent you another sheet which is a
comparison
of our latest revenues in the
in the house bill 2 editions in
comparison to the governors
and we can we'll just go over those
at the end of the meeting today
so any questions before we start
no questions
the first bill is house bill
32 creating an animal records database
uh any discussion do we need any more
information is it sufficient
can we take action tomorrow
and raise your hand representative
romney
uh just so there's some discussion on
this um
so my reading of this there's really
only two spots
that work we need to be concerned with
page four
uh section 4 on line 16
and to line 25 and then
section 5 line 26 to 34
which basically allows
a transfer of money out of the two
dedicated funds
to to help fund this
setting up of this database i just want
to make sure
that is what those are the two things
only that we're dealing with
uh uh is i guess that's a question to
the chair
in my reading i agree
unless somebody found something else
okay and then can i have a follow-up
comment representative romney
this bill is similar to the bill we had
last year
um that passed through ways and means
it went on to the senate but again like
many other bills uh it was tabled
without a hearing uh and correct me if
i'm wrong
that i think that's what happened with
this one
so we're familiar with it um it's
changed
last year there were i think there was a
fee
to help fund the ongoing
the ongoing maintenance of this database
but i guess they're going to the general
fund
again this year so but that that's
uh so i with all of that
uh i'm okay with the transferring of the
funds
uh it's just my comment thank you
representative thank you mr chairman
um i checked over in division one
and they have have got
the uh an extra i.t person
and the 250 000 per year
in the agriculture budget and they've
approved it
and uh the two
we were worried about the rating of the
dedicated funds being paid
back that's what the fees were for on
and the uh
there is enough money in there so that
those funds can survive
because for several years they were not
on doing the work they were supposed to
be doing so they
had money saved up and
they can survive without this on
i think there is a serious question of
what they're
how they're using the animal products
fund but that's something that
would have to be dealt with in a
different bill or
over in the the dedicated fund committee
we're starting in the dedicated fund
committee
so on i don't see anything else that we
need to do this
this year thanks okay representative
amanda gordon thank you um
just to correct one thing that
uh representative um
abrami said as the chair of ena
the last term it actually did pass both
the house and the senate
it was put in one of the omnibus bills
and then it was vetoed
so it actually did pass both bodies just
to let everybody know
thank you amanda i know i know it passed
it
made it a certain distance i wasn't sure
if it made it through the senate or not
but no worries yeah very confusing a lot
of the ena bills
um actually got trapped in the omnibus
bills and
last term we actually only passed one
bill out of my committee
so it's all good well thank you for that
for that correction
appreciate it i don't see any
other hands raised so it looks like
we're all set
as an ought to pass tomorrow on this
bill
i don't see anybody in opposition so
we'll go
to house bill
610.
x10 is requiring certain licenses and
reporting functions
be conducted through the nationwide
multi-state licensing system and
registry
and relative to the background and
investigation
of trust officers to certain filing fees
assessments and interest rates into the
transmission of consumer complaints by
the banking department
that was sponsored by representative
hunt
representative romney again i'll do the
same just to get the conversation going
uh we're on i think we're talking about
page six
way down the bottom line 36
we're only talking about moving a fee
from 10 000
to 15 000 is that correct mr chair
uh yes okay and we we also had this bill
last year
and i will not attempt to take a stab at
what happened but it obviously
didn't make it through to the uh
it passed the house i'm not sure what
happened
after that in the senate but it's back
to us to this
this week so uh this uh this year so
uh my understanding was that that 10
000 was too low and that they could
capture a lot more
uh by raising it to the 15 000
which was close to what the average was
of cost
to uh to do the work for uh
chartering new banks and credit unions
state banks and credit unions
it made sense to me last year if it
makes sense to me this year
thank you okay representative
thank you just to add on they also
are adding the ability for them to
assess
more money if the project extends past
that 15 000 on because some
some of the banking requests they get
are huge
but on if they pay for them out of their
general fund
which is covered by bank assessments all
the other banks would have to pay for
this one
project and they feel that that's unfair
it's a bank asking to become
on on registered
and that was a very important point
you see anybody else was to comment
anybody in to
tomorrow recommend ought to pass on this
since now we go to
house bill 614
the house still six foot
and house bill 614 is exempting the
state
and political subdivision from payments
of the cost of
compliance the renewable portfolio
standards
this came to us as amended by the house
we'll come to find out mike floss this
is chairman of the
science and technology is that
the amendment that was passed
that they thought that they passed is
not the amendment that you see
in this bill so what needs to be done
and i would have to check with the
speaker to see if we could do it
is to get the correct amendment
and amend this bill to do that but we're
not the committee
to do this really because this needed a
public hearing
mike ross called me this morning he's
prepared
an amendment to correct this
but my recommendation on this is so
confusing
the bill as we received it
is not what they thought that they had
passed
so and i talked to mike boss this
morning
my recommendation is that we retain this
so that work with my boss
and recommend that they provide a new
bill
in january which corrects this
anybody else having different
mr chairman representative
if they're going to provide a new bill
in january
wouldn't it be better to itl this one
with the recommendat reference
that the committee asked that it be
be killed so that a new bill could come
forward next year
rather than add to our retained list
what they really wanted to do
is provide us an amendment
to this bill so that we would amend it
and carry it forth because i feel it's
necessary
but i explained we
never had a public hearing on that
amendment
and we're not the committee to do that
it's a policy committee
so to be nice
to be nice we would retain it and we
would end up doing that rather than army
um
yes we could itl it because of this
but i have no problem retaining it
thank you um yes i i support
i think that's a an appropriate
response to the situation to retain and
uh
and then um we'll see how it how it
flows but uh
probably a new bill corrected bill
in january would be
what we would see and we would deal with
the retained bill
appropriately and i think uh
sort of in support of that is uh that
um the
impact of an exemption for the political
subdivisions is
turns out to be pretty complicated that
i'm guilty of sending
uh quite a lot of information to the
rest of the committee
and i've been pouring over it and trying
to understand this
it's uh it's complicated it's the kind
of stuff that really should be addressed
by the policy committee
and so i think this uh way of proceeding
allows for that allows for a public
hearing where people can
provide additional input on that issue
and
so i favor the approach thank you
representative
who representative oh
representative ruler we had to stand up
before mine oh
okay you know representing you
well but that's that's fine but there's
no urgency on this bill is that correct
mr chair
the bill is is doesn't do what they run
if you can do
so it needs to be corrected one way or
the other
and i think uh by retaining
let them do it is the proper way of
doing it
absolutely
representative romney yeah mine's a
question of the chair um
have we already gotten guidance from the
house clerk
on this no okay so there may be an
option that if we retain it that somehow
we can work on it in the fall but
either way i'm fine whether we retain it
and
and kill it kill it or retain it and we
have the ability to work on it
with the final view of the clerk um
as to giving us guidance as to how far
we can take this
but again the amendment has nothing to
do with us i don't think
and that would make it very difficult
for us to um
move that amendment forward as my guess
but
i support either way we were going to
retain it i was going to
talk to the speaker and the clerk okay
um get some guidance interrupted
hacking phillips
mr chair i think it's important for me
to just reflect my constituency by
saying
we would prefer to itl this bill um
given the fact that it's not the format
that
is even the preferred format and that my
community is strongly against it i
would just move to kill it
when we get to that point i guess thank
you representative phillips
uh
[Music]
jordan you still have your hand up yes i
do um
regarding uh the working session on this
or retaining the bill
if for some reason the speaker says that
a similar bill cannot be re
reintroduced having it retained gives us
the ability to have
a joint committee over the summer
uh where this could be vetted with
both science and technology and ways and
means
and get it done in one large committee
format or large zoom format with it
however you two guys you and ross want
to work it out
uh would that be correct sir right
isn't it great when we can discuss
things because we kind of forget things
if we do itl it they cannot
bring it a new bill in in january
if we retain it
they can do that and we can and then if
the speaker
in the clerk says that in retain
we can
have a public hearing and do all those
things necessary
to change it fine so by eye telling it
it's dead
and it won't be coming back next year
anybody else
all right then tomorrow we're going to
speak mr
chairman yes
term on representative obama
was allowed to bring back the horse
racing bill
intact with the new amendment that had
been put on it when it went to the floor
on because the speaker said so
on their the speaker has complete
discretion over what is
different from the bill that god i tell
you and that's been true for quite a
long time though i don't remember it
ever happening the way that one did
uh so on
i and especially
when the itl is we've done this before
when the itl is accompanied
by on the committee has asked that
we did this actually last term with a
transportation bill uh the committee has
asked that we itl is bill so they can
bring
forward the correction that they want to
the bill
well the committee and talking to the
chairman
has asked for retaining it
representative romney i just want to
react to
uh what the representative army said
yeah the historic racing bill
um when i went to the speaker he
deferred to the head uh dave i always
forget his last name but
uh the the head of uh office of
legislative service
who made the decision and he said that
the bill was
different enough than the original bill
that he was he allowed it
that's that's what happened i i he
basically the speaker deferred to
ols speaker told me that he'd
read the original bill and realize that
the
amended bill which is the one that went
to the floor was different
right but and and but uh but the speaker
conferred with the head of alas you may
not know that part of the story
that's what happened i had to sit down
with the ols to explain
to him what what the differences were
do we want to wait uh waste our
ammunition
for a battle on this thing
we're we haven't kind of an agreement
that it can be handled
peacefully
represents the occasion
uh thank you mr chairman i i just wanted
to say where it seems like there's
there's some um concern as to whether we
could bring the bill back or not
and not knowing if it'll be different
enough and how the speaker
will react it does seem prudent to uh
retain and then decide
at a later date how to move forward
thank you okay so that tomorrow the
debate will be whether the retained or
ital
i don't think uh walter represented
stillsbury
thank you mr chairman i believe the only
difference between the bill as we heard
it
and the amendment is the addition of the
very brief
subparagraph e at the end so
they're identical except for that little
edition and i certainly
am comfortable retaining it
all right anybody else wants to
make a comment saying none
house bill 615 dash fm
an act reducing the penalty for certain
first offense
drug possession charges
that
okay um on house bill 615
represent our branding followed by
representative
these are the kind of bills i hate well
we have to
weigh in on fines i'm assuming that's
what we're supposed to weigh in on
is the reduction of the fines
first off is that is that your read uh
mr chair
i wasn't paying attention to that all
right yeah uh
it appears that we're supposed to
address the fines here
and the reduction of the fines is that
the essence of what what's the deals
okay none of the policies just the plan
right
just the fines well right and uh you
know
they're also reducing sentences which i
guess we don't address but we address
the reduction of the fines uh
so uh my only concern
um is is
we had in the testimony it was said this
has nothing to do with drug dealers
but it actually does is the more you
read the
uh to read it especially the first
section uh
it it does it reduces their from uh
their
fines from five hundred thousand to
three three hundred fifty thousand
and then the rest of the bill is in
increments it's in increments of
quantity so as you go through this
you can see um a certain drug
if it's five ounces or more it's this
fine if it's
you know half that it's another fine
um so i i'm a
for certain of these i'm concerned about
i'm letting my own personal bias in here
about i'm concerned about
lowering some of these fines uh
the other that's one number two as ways
and means uh there's
really no there's a fiscal note but
there's no fiscal note on um
on what this would do to the the fine
revenue
um you know and i understand
that a lot of these fines are very large
uh and it came out in the testimony that
that many times the fines aren't paid
uh i understand that but i think we'd
need at least a sense of uh of what the
impact is
on the uh on the revenue if we can
uh uh my my sense is that we should
retain this bill
that's just my a comment uh from my
perspective
uh to allow us to uh to look at this a
little more closely
thank you thank you representative
representative alame followed by
representatives also
thank you mr chairman
my sense on this is that we have never
dealt with the
criminal fines partly because the fines
were not supposed to be
really related to revenue and in fact
they produce almost no revenue
for us partly because
people frequently can't pay them and the
judges
relieve them of that payment
and i think that what we're looking at
is
policy of criminal justice it shouldn't
have come to us
and that we ought to send it on to the
senate and have
the the different uh
sides fight out the policy again
in the senate which is probably going to
have a different take on this
thank you representative
thank you mr chairman so
again this has already passed the house
i think it is
mostly a policy bill and i'm just not
sure what we could accomplish as a
committee
really looking at the fines i believe
there was testimony that judges
are already going to the lower end
so i would probably give it an opt to
pass again it's not my favorite kind of
bill either
thank you
thank you representative software
anybody else want to weigh in on this
all right then tomorrow uh was debating
whether
we retained this bill or not to pass
the next is house bill 624
decreasing the fee to file a petition
for a declaratory ruling
with a site evaluation committee
comments
thank you do we have on diane martin
in the audience to talk to us again
about what it means to file a petition
for declaratory ruling
and whether on this is an avenue
that ordinary citizens which is what
the bill was talking about giving access
to
would use as versus the petition to
uh for a uh committee jurisdiction which
already has what they were trying to
achieve
in it for ordinary citizens i think
except that
it may have too many citizens
i don't see a diane martin in there no
oh dear she's
the the head of the puc now
she didn't talk to us before about that
she she sent us this
with the yellow highlighted sections
and and i looked up a declaratory ruling
in the statutes i had to search
the entire statutes it appears
in the chapter on
on administrative procedures 541a
and it is for the entire government
and it's when someone is
is protesting an agency ruling
on as to the specific
applicability of any statutory provision
of any rule or order of the agency
and it applies to the entire government
okay representative romney followed by
representative ames
i can't recall maybe someone
a member can uh answer this
was there for this petition to be filed
did it have to be a certain number of
citizens or just except one person can
do it
does anybody recall that i could answer
that if you want
on in number one
the petition for committee jurisdiction
on there is a paragraph about that
and as i read it it required a hundred
citizens
to sign up in order to have a free
hearing
so you need a hundred to have a free
hearing okay that seemed like rather a
lot
yeah but if i could also add to that
um it's it's one person for a
request for a declaratory ruling
just one person is there any
qualifications to that dick
on a butter or anything like that no
just pay your fee
just pay your fee okay now the only
other
what the fee is what then well that's
what we're talking about
so uh again they were
from her testimony it sounds uh the note
i have is that there were three of these
filed since 2015 is
my note so it doesn't it's not
many but i guess with this it could open
the floodgates to
making a lot more if if if the um
if the the current fee structure was
kept in place so
so what we're talking about is whether
we're going to have a
fee uh no fee or a reduced fee
for for these hearings if you ask
for them not whether you can ask for
them as a single person or not
that's a policy decision
now the fee is our decision the
fee amount is our decision but the
policy decision is whether
you're even going to consider a fee
yeah what i was trying to get at though
my question or comment was you know for
an individual
uh you know ten thousand five hundred
it's a lot
uh if it's a group it's you know you
could spread it over that
and i know i mean the bill what we're
addressing is one thing
should we reduce that to 250 dollars
that's all we're talking about here um
and i guess we got a
mr chair could i speak to this
representative
yeah yeah
what what's being proposed the core of
the bill
is to reduce the uh the current fee
which is um
either ten thousand five hundred dollars
or three thousand
thousand dollars depending on whether
it's heard by the full
committee which is the ten thousand five
hundred dollar number or three thousand
dollars if it's heard by a three-member
sub-committee and
reducing that down to 250
so um it seems to me
looking at this that the
from a policy perspective the uh
the choice that's represented by this
change is
to open up this option to get a ruling
a declaratory ruling
make it easier to access that
opportunity by reducing the
rate it seems to me that that is a
policy judgment
right it did occur to me
that to the extent to which ways and
means
can second guess that
judgment because it does cross over into
fees
it uh would make sense to me
um sort of responding to the concern
that this may open the floodgates
so to speak or gum up the works whatever
expression you want to use
um that they're we ensure that there is
a provision or existing capacity
for the sec to
dismiss summarily those petitions that
it finds to be either redundant or
frivolous
so that the sec could pull itself out of
a situation where there's a cascade of
petitions that are
essentially coming up the works um now
i don't know i haven't had time we
haven't had time to
look at sec's procedures i don't think
we've
got anybody here in the uh
panel in the attendee list who can speak
to this
whether the sec already has that
authority but i think that's an
important part of reducing a fee like
this
that the sec should have the tools
that it may need in particular
situations
to to go on with this business and not
end up spending an enormous amount of
money um
because a lot of people now find it easy
to file
uh petitions on a single issue a hot
issue
you make a good point representative
ames
that in order to get that information
without
somebody representing the sec that
understands it
to be able to explain it to us
and if that's the case then it probably
would be a
fine candidate for retaining
i think so yeah
uh represented uh you're already
followed by spillsboro and
denise representatively
oh thank you mr chair i wanted to uh
i don't know i don't like doing this too
often but
if you would take a look at the new
hampshire constitution
um maybe representative ames can correct
me if i'm wrong
but we modified part one article eight
in 2018 providing that standards
providing the taxpayers have standing to
bring actions against the government
and then again in article 14
it says that legal remedies are to be
free complete
and prompt so when we're talking about
setting a ten thousand dollar
piling fee to get uh
what's that called a um presumptive uh
hearing
or uh on a decline
yeah declaratory thank you a
representative said
skip me for a moment to get a
declaratory
ruling are we in fact
violating both article 8 as
it was changed in 2018 and
article 14 which says that it needs to
be at least
free to a degree um
well it actually in article 14 it says
free period
but we've put in filing fees and
exemptions for that and stuff like that
you know that's what we do
but i i think we need to take those into
consideration when we're setting a
ten thousand dollar filing fee
regardless of what
sec wants to put down um
ten cents thank you representative
uh yes thank you mr chairman so
at the current fee level there have
apparently only been three
declaratory rulings requested in the
last five years
so from a revenue perspective this is
absolutely negligible
and i don't think that the ways and
means committee should step in and
meddle i think this one gets a pass
in deference to the policy committee it
was passed on
february 24th on a voice vote on the
floor
so i'm ready to let it go forward
representative thank you mr chairman
i guess my concern i understand that the
policy committee
has made a ruling on this but i guess
the one thing that has bothered me
throughout
this is that there was a ten thousand
dollar or ten thousand five hundred if
the full committee
uh made a declaratory ruling
and three thousand if it was a
three-member panel
yes there were only three judgments but
you know are we opening is it going to
open the floodgates and if so
it makes no sense to me it's never made
sense to me that
it's the same price 250 whether it's the
whole
committee or it's only a three-member
committee i mean to me
i guess i would vote to retain because i
think
we need to look at these fees and maybe
you know obviously the policy committee
has decided it should be lower
but maybe it should be um you know 3 000
if the whole committee hears it and and
i don't know 500 if
or 250 if it's a three-member panel but
we do know
uh through the testimony that the cost
of the hearing
would outweigh the um the fee certainly
if it's lowered so
i think i i would i would vote to retain
and and reassess these fees and have
a fee for the full member panel and a
fee for the three-member panel
thank you representative
thank you mr chairman on i would like to
know from the lawyers
whether they feel that the
constitutional amendment that we passed
refers only to our court system or
also to all of our regulatory agencies
in which case
we are going to have to dedicate a lot
more general funds to those regulatory
agencies
in order to replace the fees
that that they charge on
this fee was based on the idea
that the fact that if they have a full
committee commission uh hearing
they have to pay for i think it's three
commissioners
at commission level they can't send
delegates
uh as well as a number of other people
to come and spend maybe days on
something
on and
we should when we look at fees
both look at what can be afforded and
look
at on what pays for the service
that's what a fee is supposed to be
doing it's supposed to pay for
the service on and
in this case what pays for the service
seems to be this very
large amount because of the way the rest
of the statute was written
so um but i would like to see what the
lawyers have to say about
the regulatory agencies being being
affected by the constitutional amendment
we passed that
i at least was thinking about as uh
on the court system itself i think
thank you susan any any other
comments
i'm 6 24 represent early
now i was just going to thank
representative ames for that comment
yeah um
i don't think that has uh been
determined by the supreme court as yet
although they
you know the reason we put that in is
because they uh
had stated that uh uh the house of
representatives didn't have standing
before the court
well it seems to me that the house of
representatives should have
and the senate individually and jointly
should have standing in everything but
that's why that was put through if i
remember the discussion
um on it but it would be nice to know
whether
this is applying to uh agencies because
uh
representative ames is correct it's
going to cost more
if agencies are free for
seeking quote-unquote justice uh from
something as simple as the dmv
uh we have to pay a fee to
exist
representative romney followed by
representatives
um my sense is that i
may have been something that was said in
the hearing is that
these fees don't cover the costs that
some of the money comes out of the
general fund i guess
into their budget to the site evaluation
committee uh budget to cover the costs
uh what we don't know the other thing we
do know is that
uh these whether it's a three-member
panel or the full
uh the full board or whatever
that some members are employees of the
state
in our own salary so those costs are
already fixed those costs are already in
the in their budget
and then others are outside members and
what we just don't know
is and i'm sure these hearings are of
different lengths
so we just don't know what the actual
cost is here
i'll just throw that out as it may be a
reason to
to retain to try to understand a little
better if we really want to dig into
this
uh how close is the current
the current fee structure to
what the actual cost is of uh performing
this
uh that's just a comment mr chair
representative uh ames followed by
representative
yeah i i thought i should at least say a
few words in response to
uh representative ulrich and represents
almi's
request and i don't want to pretend
expertise here that i don't have
and the question is of
the effect of the constitutional recent
relatively recent
constitutional amendment i think that
was directed at taxpayer
standing to bring cases in court
and that
[Music]
essentially acted as a reversal of uh
recent
rulings that had made it more difficult
for taxpayers to
gain standing to challenge this that or
the other thing
and so we're talking about a different
scene here
regulatory agencies
perhaps there's some aspect of that
amendment
that strengthens the
the case for an individual to be able to
get before a regulatory agency but i
think it's
it's that vague and and you know who
knows how the court would rule on that i
think we just need to look
straight head on at this particular
provision and and
deal with it as is and not get uh not
get sidetracked by
speculation which is essentially what it
has to be
as to the import of recent or
ancient constitutional provisions
that can only be interpreted
authoritatively by our supreme court
thank you i also asked division one
about the sec budget they
uh in in the budget at this point
they have taken all general funding away
from the sec and told them to raise
their own money
on by which they seem to mean that
they're going to be playing with their
own fees
on this and they
and i discovered when i looked at the
amendments
on hb1 they still have an asterisk on
the sec
saying if you can't raise enough you can
come to the fiscal committee and try to
get some more money
um so what that
the department of energy which is 40
of hb2 is on
messing completely with everything to do
with energy including
all of the puc the sec everything
we've been talking about in those two
bills and until that is
ironed out at the end of the budget
process i don't think if we're going to
be looking at
on this service is supposed to be
performed how
how how do you handle the fees for it i
don't think we can
deal with that we don't have no idea
what's going to come out at the end of
the budget
thing thank you representative
any further comments
then
deal with that tomorrow and
i would imagine representing you're
going to be having a caucus of your
members
today we'll be having our caucus this
afternoon of our members
i'm going to try i haven't heard yet on
from more than one of them whether they
could come and when
i can't be there after three o'clock
okay well if we're through early enough
today
you'll have a greater choice of time
for the next group of the senate bills
that we
have heard
so long one second
the longer we're at this the more paper
we generate
when it gets mixed up
so
all right
we'll go to center bill 22
relative to the sale of lucky 17.
do we need any more information to make
a decision
on this
um
and senate bill top 22 that's all it
says
to the second seven tickets it allows
the play of elected like the seven
games sets a limit for elected seven
deal size
the commission they authorize and sets
the max
maximum price per election seven ticket
representative brandon yeah we
we received a document from
um
oh jeez i'm losing his name um rick
newman
thank you rick newman uh i'm just trying
to check here
he's suggesting to combine a couple of
these bills
i don't know if 25 was one of them or
not um
yeah it is it is yeah um
so there's i mean this bill has three
this bill has three components
one is to do away with the piece of
paper that comes out the bottom
of the machine increase the deal size to
14 000 tickets
and basically to add the 25 cent ticket
back into the
grouping which would make mary happy
um so there's you know
i hate these bills but uh
uh i don't know
yes the paper coming out the bottom yes
it's a waste of paper no one looks at it
uh but i don't know if if getting rid of
that is
um i mean that
these these machines were agreed to
because of that piece of paper
is all i recall from way back when
um and then the deal size
i mean i understand the logic uh there's
more potential winners
um i don't really have a feeling either
way on it um
other than it's already happening and
that they come at least for the machines
they're
they're already combining uh deals
up to three deals to equal the 14 000
tickets in the machines
and then i would support the section
three
uh the 25 cent ticket
so i don't know i know this is my
comments
okay
thank you first on i think we received
this magnum opus from rick newman
late last night i haven't had a chance
to
read through it yet i think i
understand what he's doing but what they
are trying to do
and mary is very opposed to this by the
way
um she i don't think was told we're
doing senate bills
today and she has to pay long distance
charges to participate
uh which makes it pretty difficult for
her
but on the what they are doing
is is finalizing turning
these dispenser machines which is all we
approved
originally and the reason for the paper
ticket and the reason that you would not
be combining deals across
machines into a
uh essentially pretty slow
on but slot machine type of machine
on a playing machine in which you play
on to on
to on win
under the na win randomly under the name
of lucky seven tickets
and as i understand they they did
admit this and the lottery
director admitted that that's what they
were doing
on and that they need to do this in
order to be able to tell the
massachusetts people that are coming
across the border
that on yes we've got slot machines too
so so that more of them would come
on which may make
perfect sense to to them and the
question is whether
this is a policy that
we want to engage in but the second
question is
we just got this amendment and i don't
think that we really ought to finish
discussing this
and vote on it tomorrow unless we're
going to vote retained tomorrow
thank you right
and we're just senate bill we have a lot
of time
what i want to do is those senate bills
that look
clean and that we can dispose of
right away fine and then we have
a smaller number of bills to work on
so mr chairman i think this
this um relate this comment
and your comment relate to four of these
bills
will someone find out
any representative ames
yeah um
i think it's good that we've got a
little extra time because that means we
can make a
make some judgment uh without
necessarily retaining and making
perhaps adopting an amendment i think
that
on one one level rick newman
is absolutely right that these bills
need to be combined
they overlap they repeat uh you know
that uh the only sensible way to proceed
is
to combine but um once you do that you
get into
uh and perhaps perhaps that
it's better not to combine for this
reason that
when you combine then you get the
controversial pieces in with the
non-controversial adjustments like
probably whether a member of the charity
needs to be
present that kind of thing um
so i i think taking taking more time we
really need more time to
have this amendment in front of us and
sort through it
decide whether maybe one of the single
bills should be put
forward that uh changes something that
we all agree on and just let it go
and then um you know discuss the paper
um issue and uh so forth but uh
but we need we need more time and we
just got this i i did look it through i
i understand everything yes 22
and 25 we need to work on
both of those
is that what i hear i'm 23 and 27.
possibly 23 that one is is um
just changing i think it's just changing
when whether the person has to be there
right so that that could be separated
out but you know whatever
okay and then 27
[Music]
uh mr chair uh 27 i think is the one
that needs
some work because of the irs codes we
were going to investigate
uh yeah sounds like uh we want to make
sure that
that um we're capturing the
the codes that include the charities
that want to participate
in in uh terrible gaming um
we have 22
25 and 27
and that we're going to hold because it
needs more work
is that correct right maybe 23.
let's talk about 23 right now okay
23 uh that says just
changing the requirement that a member
of the sponsoring charitable
organization be present
during certain danger chance
represent southwest oh thank you mr
chairman
i think this is one we could exec it
seems to just make common sense
and we could just get it off our list
okay representative i second that
thank you uh could i ask the people who
had time
to read nick rick newman's i thought i
saw
material in there with which was
cleaning up some of the language that
follows this
that assigns responsibilities to the
charitable organizations
that they delegate back but i'm not sure
because i remember being told that
the delegation was somewhere in that
other language
already i didn't have time to read
rick newman's piece senate bill 23 it's
a very simple
issue
do we feel we can dispose of this
tomorrow
the recommendation is yes so we will
discuss senate bill
23 tomorrow that's the first one
out of six senate bill 48
relative to the formula used to
determine current use tax rates
and what this one does is
it makes that formula public
seems like a today when we want to
make sure that
everything is as transparent as we can
comment and representative broadly yes i
think this is ready to go
tomorrow and uh
my understanding is that the dra has no
problem with this uh
with this bill they feel that
uh it it will not violate any of their
roles if we
if we did this
uh any comments contrary to that
okay then we will deal with that one
tomorrow
the last one is senate bill 103.
relative to the nexus provision for
certain disaster related or emergency
related work
performed in the state and this is an
important bill put in by senator
brackley
comments
represent southwest again to me this is
in the uh
practical common sense category and i
didn't see any problems with it so
i think we could pass it
uh representative romney yeah
and talking to the dra a little further
about this um
i think they may be they'd like to
suggest an amendment to this
uh so can we hold on this tomorrow and
possibly have another work session on it
uh yes any further comments
then we're gonna hold on this for the
work session and take a look at
or discuss the proposed amendment
with the dra so from that group
mr chairman yes when we get the dra back
could we also get the on
the uh either i suppose owen smith from
a t and t are one of the people that
need this so that they could talk
with us about whether this would make it
uh
apparently they're trying to pass
exactly the same bill everywhere so that
they won't run into
to on longer periods before they can get
stuff done
in an emergency yeah i think what i've
read as far as says
they've passed this in 33 states i
believe
but to me my observation
makes good sense
all right so we will wait until we
discuss
with the dra a possible amendment
so out of this group of six pills mr
chair
um uh representative uh twitter tutors
had his hand up
and i just
yes mr chairs is kind of a rookie
question senate bill 25
as written is very clean and probably
could be pushed through tomorrow
i didn't know if the amendment against
it could be changed to one of the other
bills that needs work
and then you could push 25 through
comments on representative tudors
comments on 25.
mr chairman 25 is repeated
in another bill that was part of the
problem
that they passed this one and then they
passed one that included it
but if we passed 25 as a standalone
they wouldn't need that in the other
bill
yeah we could take it out
yeah back to 25. uh
no i'm not no i'm i'm
back one bill back to senate bill 103.
hold on a minute i want to get 25 okay
my hand was up
since then that's all so i'll i'll i'll
wait
representative tudor made his comment
of why we should handle 25 tomorrow i'd
like to
clear the depth of this one
so if you've got a comment on 25
representatives
yeah i i have no problem um
going forward with that it's it's common
sense
um and uh
i mean common sense says that we should
combine these bills but but
uh it's easy to go forward with these
individual bills and i have no problem
going forward with this
and then we'll deal with uh the more
comprehensive bills that
that we'd be holding and looking more
closely at and take
this provision out of that if we've gone
forward with it already
any further comment on senate bill 25
senator bromley yeah i concur right
i think we can move forward the lottery
the lottery it's my understanding the
lottery commission would like to see
this
they just make their life a little
easier in terms of
uh re-licensing people
okay then at this point in time
tomorrow we hope to act on senate bill
23 and 48
and others you want to reconsider
representative brown there no i just it
was just a comment on
senate bill 103.
again
say again senate bill 103
um okay so
the the was as was mentioned this is a
boilerplate bill
that states are adopting okay
and i think the dra when it looked at
the language just for everybody
when they looked at the language it had
to do with attacks
given that we're a little different than
of the states they felt that a uh
an amendment was needed so that's that's
the basis of their amendment
so we'll talk about this more i guess
once we uh
take it up thank you okay
tomorrow we're going to act on the sex
times hold on one second
and the five house bills which is 532
614 615 and 624
and three senate bills
23 25 and 48.
and then we'll schedule work sessions
on senate bill
22 27 103.
before i get into the revenue part
for the for the republicans what's a
good time to do a
uh caucus this afternoon
it's two o'clock okay
that works for me this is representative
this is representative sooner than later
is better for me this afternoon
well one o'clock norm
um so how how long are we gonna go it's
it's only uh 10 15
is it possible to do it like 15 minutes
after we're done
how much longer you think we're going to
be uh we're not going to be
much longer yeah we could would it be
better for our
members of the republican caucus to meet
15 minutes after we're done give you
time to get the zoom link out
get the link out right because that's
better for me
for the republicans yes
okay fine but susan do you
want to query your talk
i think that we wouldn't have any
problem going straight to a caucus
after this if um amanda
could we use your link again of course
and i'll send it out
great on the but
i have another question about whether we
are you want us to work at all next week
because next week is likely to be full
of budget consultations and things
i need to put placeholders
see like today i had this week i had to
put
i didn't know when we would get the
information to me
because i'm trying to get somebody that
is an
expertise on the stimulus package
and jennifer's working on that and
a few others and once that happens i
want to bring them in
to the committee and uh so if i
say okay such and such a day's revenues
then i can use that day but if i don't
have it in the calendar i have to wait
another way
so for this week we should finish our
work for this week
tomorrow morning so we won't have to
meet thursday
but i had a placeholder in case we
didn't something happened
we needed them and i want to put a
couple placeholders in for the following
yeah well representative ames and i
probably cannot participate on tuesday
next week
okay i'm not sure about the rest of the
week i can't as i told you i can't
participate on wednesday uh getting my
shot
my last one and i'm not sure on
what the effects will be after that so
all over the place for next week thank
you
so you can't meet at all on tuesday
on we don't know exactly when they're
going to schedule it yet
but on we too on
are going to be in a ranking dems
meeting
that is going to go a long time
you available wednesday morning
uh i personally am only available to
to 10 30 at the latest because i have to
get myself to kanan
okay we'll talk off offline on that but
we need to have
we do have a lot of time after
after crossover
we've done a lot of the senate bills
we're likely to get
and the later we wait the more accurate
information we're going to get about
what the treasurer decided about the
stimulus
before the budget passes
and sure we need to get together again
because i
we have had discussions in our party
relative to things in house bill 2.
there are suggestions that have come up
that are different
than what we have agreed on
and
i think we need to address those as they
come up
and we can address them if we
put in the calendar that we have
placeholders for these
otherwise we wouldn't be doing our job
we just on that particular issue we are
not going to have enough
information they're arguing it out in dc
and they're going to be arguing for a
while probably going to have to go
through the courts
on the stimulus if there's other things
other than the stimulus that could
affect
revenues that people are thinking about
and i think we need to
have a position from this committee
the position from this committee carries
a lot of weight
a position from one or two of us doesn't
represent
a committee position and
they're looking for
what does the ways and means committee
feel if we do
this or that
such as maybe doing the ied
retirement in two years rather than five
years
like that anyway
anything else before a couple of
things i want to talk about real quick
you stand right now
romney so uh it's
is in our understanding that ppp
bill was the senate bill 3 has passed
and it's heading our way now the
quickness of that i i
my sense is that everybody's going to
want a quick turn on that bill from us
so that's the only big variable for next
week
and i think we can if that bill does
come to us
i'm sure we can work around
representative army's schedule as well
as
you know the the the ways and means
democrat schedule
uh to uh possibly take that up next week
depending on your your your view of the
sense of the urgency of uh
that we get from leadership as to uh how
quick of a turn they want on ppp bill
the ppp bill
is understanding that bill
and the ramification is important for
all of us
to get that understanding before the
budget passes
and if that comes to us i want to be
able to do that
before the budget pass and all we have
is next week especially the week after
that
yeah the week after that as we're tied
up the whole week
or three days with sessions
mr chairman if we do the ppp bill next
week
can it get into the calendar
find out tomorrow how soon is coming
if i know it's coming we will be
and i might even put a placeholder
senate bills
and then get amendment to the calendar
but it's it's important that we
understand the ramification of that bill
when we start passing the budget
any further comments before okay if
there's not
i sent you an email this morning
and the email just has two parts for it
the email has the
amendment to house bill 1
that has the revenues that our committee
agreed to in it so
house bill 1 goes to the floor you'll
see amendment
0924 and it's
an amendment sponsored by weiler and
major
and it has our revenues as we
proposed exactly
also this morning i sent you a revenue
comparison
sheet i hope you were able to
in that revenue comparison sheet the
whole idea of that
is to take these revenues that we had
passed
along the house bill two changes that we
had agreed on
and compare those revenues to what the
governor proposed
so i hope that
do you all have it
that sheet on that sheet
it has the house ways and means revenue
under current law for 22 and 23
which is the 2764 and the 2805
and then the house bill 2 changes
after you put all the changes in
which reduces the revenue 22 by 10.6
million so we have a number of pluses
and a number of minuses
the minuses were the bet tax credits and
things like that
and the offsetting vpt
revenues so that
the again the hospital
two changes were minus ten point six
million
and minus six point four in the second
year
the house weighs in means total come up
to be
2.7534 billion dollars
and 22 and 2.7941 billion and 23.
the governor's revenue
that he had proposed
they started off with 2748
and 22 and 27 99.9 and 23.
and house built two changes in the first
year
reduced his revenues 46.5 million
dollars
in the second year 81.6
and the biggest part of those is due to
the
credit carryover
and so therefore the governor's totals
was 2701 and 27
18. the house was
51 51.9 million dollars ahead of the
governor in 22
and 75.8 ahead of the governor
and 23. the reason why
we don't have as much
of a decrease household two
as we put a house bill to a memonine
which they agreed on that house bill two
amendment
changes the credit carry over and you
have that information
so it's done using
the 500 percent
200 percent and 100 spread out
so the effect in the first year was only
four million dollars
in the second year 11 million dollars if
we took
about seven eighty percent the first
year eighty percent the second year
and that is what's going into house bill
two
as part of the budget i just wanted to
make sure to bring this up to you
okay now there is a
question floating out there how about if
we change the
house the interest and dividend
roll back for two years rather than the
four years
and
when they do that
[Music]
it could affect
revenues
like 12 million dollars the first year
rather than four
in the second year approximately 52
million dollars
and uh instead of our
11 million dollars so it still is going
to happen
and that is to reduce them by that
amount
so if it would add another
12 million dollar reduction the first
year
and if i take away the 6.4
probably another 44 million dollars
the second year reduction in revenues so
that's been considered
i just wanted to bring you up to date on
and i'm sure things are gonna come up
tomorrow
and the day after each day
and if we need to call you back
so that we can evaluate and do that and
those that can join us
will be appreciated questions
mr chairman you do realize
that if you do that on
you will be on on
refusing any help from the
american rescue plan for new hampshire
as i understand it maybe
reps in advance it's got that a little
clearer than i do
and that's the one that is being argued
about in dc
that's why we need to get somebody to
meet with us
that understands what they passed in
and what we can and what we can't do and
what the ramifications
will be when we do it
and if we can get somebody next week
i'm going to schedule it i'm going to
put placeholders in
any further questions or comments
i i have a question a representative
so i know that you and
others on ways and means have been
concerned about the credit carryover
issue for some time
but i don't think it's been a general
interest in the state
are you finding that people understand
quickly the concept
behind why there's been concern
and why now something has been passed to
deal with it
right most people have no idea what it
is
and those that those that how does how
do we
how do we get people to understand
enough to under
to recognize that something's being
dealt with
that leaves less money available
you know the starting point is is to
bring it up before the committee
and if the committee understands what it
is
and makes it it makes a comment
then they'll say well the committee has
looked into this this is what they come
up with and it is important
if we don't do our job this is going to
go on longer and it could get worse
you know if i was a big business you
know and i found a place where i could
park
my profits and not have to worry about
paying taxes on
this is a beautiful place
if they are forced to take it out
if they didn't target there they'd have
to pay 21
on it and then knowing that
corporate taxes probably will
possibility is going to be going up to
the old rates of 31
or more that's a lot of money
in taxes i know earlier today you
mentioned that it was important that
people understand the
transparency behind the
current use formula
but this that's minor compared to this
and i i just want to know whether you
think that's
possible for people to understand this
i think this is a case we all experience
is that we have committees
that concentrate efficient game
or health and human services or
transportation they
they concentrate on a small area of the
universe
and they go through one of these bills
thoroughly
we concentrate on revenues and then when
we come up with
those people that have no idea what's
going on we'll have faith
and and support us it's the same if we
have
faith in what they do and support them
until they really screw up
when they screw up then that support may
not be there
so do you think that is there further
changes in dividends and interest
uh taxation that the two get
mingled in people's minds or they're
quite separate
oh i think they could easily get mingled
the uh they get mingled in line i have
to make sure i'm
talking about the right thing is it that
changes is it um
cco changes is it the ind
changes the business
taxes changes
we all have a problem trying to keep
these things
in the right cells thank you very much
if i may suggest on i explained this to
mary beth waltz the other day
with just two sentences on the
state has been taking in
on more revenue than we were entitled to
for quite a long time and
on we have spent it
and we owe it to the people that left it
there
and we have to pay it back at some point
and we're going to by recognizing this
and not kicking the can down the road
we're going to reduce our liability over
time
and our risk that they'll ask for it yes
can you imagine i mean in three or four
years
it increased 100 million dollars you're
talking over a quarter of a billion
dollars
that's not our money that
could raise havoc
representing
now you're muted
sorry i said some good things would you
miss them
um they uh i i wasn't going to speak on
this
credit carryover discussion um
but i feel i need to um because
uh from my perspective it's not as
definitive a situation as
has been stated um in this discussion
uh i if you recall when we debated this
question i
i put forward the commission idea and i
said
as backup for that that the documents
that we'd received
um from the comptroller
were very informative but what they
showed to me was there
there had been an ongoing discussion of
a very complex issue
relating to um
these credits that are carried over that
uh
represent an insignificant part
a moving target the word churn was used
in
one of those documents and that i felt
that we could take time
to have a commission work on the issue
before taking
any definitive action
in the end we voted to uh take
definitive action that the chairs
already described
and i voted against that but i then
voted for
the combined commission plus taking that
low end definitive action but i would
have been comfortable just taking
the commission approach because of what
i've just said
i don't think it's as definitive a
situation as
has been um stated and
i i'd prefer to see a
exploration by a commission
composed of comprised of made up of the
of the people who can really dig into
this kind of stuff
and advise us and what uh is needed
but in any event i'm supporting the
proposal that's
now in the in out in
i guess in the pending version of house
bill 2 before the finance committee
and that's fine but i don't want it to
be
thought that that's the only way to look
at this
yeah and that commission was an
excellent
idea and it's going to
uh
be started immediately upon passage of
house bill 2.
and hopefully the way it is
now what we voted as a committee
it's only going to affect the four
million dollars
in the first year 11 million dollars the
second year
not the huge amount of
46 million and 81 million
that was in
the governor's plan because he he didn't
even put the
uh those in as we disregards they didn't
recognize
it but i think we did the right thing we
recognized it
we formed the commission based upon your
recommendation
we minimized the disruption to our
revenues by
making it the smallest amount four and
11 million dollars
and hopefully we'll get a solution by
the end of the year
representative thank you i think the
difference is that those of us
in here a long time know how hard it is
to get on something done
that's going to cost money in the budget
and by putting this in the budget now
we make it a lot easier for the
commission's
report to be on to be used to amend that
than we would if we were starting out in
yet another term
we had the education
funding commission which cost a lot of
money
now they're ignoring it we had the
uh a number of years ago the business
uh tax commission on
they picked picked a few things out of
it and left the majority of the
the conclusions even though it was run
by businessmen and
very well done i thought on we had the
business
uh the commission on a couple of years
ago
for market-based sourcing and
the single sales factor we were going to
not do the single sales factor until we
were comfortable with market-based
sourcing
uh senator and the governor jumped in
and forced us to do it
yesterday the on senate
unanimously voted uh to kill
the bill that we sent over to them about
that uh
so i'm very glad it's going into the
budget on our side so that that
conversation can continue
but it is really really hard to get
get the finance committees to
to do what is needed to be done to avoid
problems in the future
and this this gives us
a leg into getting whatever it is that
needs to be done after that commission
is done done
thank you
thank you representative
representative romney and then maybe we
should wrap it up and so we can have our
caucuses
is that going representative romney yeah
i just want to
weigh in on house bill 281 uh yes uh
both susan and i were on the
on the zoom with uh senate ways and
means yesterday
and uh i i introduced a bill
uh i testified susan testified uh
it seemed like the committee already had
their mind made up only the only
bright spot was senator d'alessandro
saying
well maybe we should take a little more
time um
and uh and involve the dra a little bit
more
uh is my recollection of what happened
and um
the surprisingly story was on the call
uh but they never called them they never
asked for their
uh testimony uh yesterday so so that
three of just while we're on that three
other bills passed that
came out of our committee they they
exact
uh the opt-in change for sports betting
the language change
no big deal um representative major's
bill
on emergency situations being able to do
multiple
revenue estimates they amended that
to say that that when we do it
to please inform the senate
so that passed and then the housekeeping
bill we have from the dra
house bill 324 uh
passed as well and fyi
uh they took up senate bill
112 112
which was is their version of the
historic racing bill
and they uh interestingly enough without
debate
uh uh passed it unanimously
thank you and doing what they did
on the single sales factor we
said that by delaying it
it would put 20 million dollars back
into the budget
now it's going to take that 20 million
dollars out of the budget
so well again we have a single swing
well we have a second bite at the apple
um since it's in the budget
yeah i imagine that'll be a committee a
conference uh thing i i
there's leverage there uh depending on
how the negotiations
go in the committee of this is why i
think it's important
that we be able to meet as these things
develop
and understand as much as we can
all the time we go to the committee
conference
um okay can we break mr chairman can i
just make one more request if
you could figure out on tuesday
when we'd be meeting maybe we can
negotiate a way that representative ames
and i can
can participate okay
um why don't we get on the phone and try
to figure that out
you work it out with rep and call me and
then
it's our problem is not us our problem
is our
is our leadership we have to have
meetings with our leadership
yeah the same or same with us
that's why tomorrow oh
why did you mention that tomorrow
representative bernstein is going to
open the meeting at
nine o'clock and then recess it until
10 30. and the reason for that
we have to have meetings of our
leadership
and so at 10 30 we will actually be
opening up meeting and we'll have our
executive session
i think okay
i sent you an email on that so
all right can we
break up now and i'll send out a link to
the republicans
and then represent
your she's going to send the link again
but we do have it so some of us
may be going in immediately thanks
okay and i'll send our link uh so that
in 15 minutes for the republicans will
caucus okay well
thank you everybody doesn't does anybody
need to show up at nine or just
alan tomorrow
um well
you need to be able to have that sign
that says
recess until 10 30. okay
yeah so as long as the two of you are
on the yeah
i'll talk with jennifer four about it
okay okay
thank you all right thank you
you